I'm playing a GM Wow let's play d5 okay
let's focus this game I'll play
something reasonable maybe play c6 I'll
play Bishop d6 so so-called Cossack
orally variation this move and castle
Queen c2 or he won so why can't playoff
three the e3 will hang 92 still probably
most common Knight f3 also a move I'll
play this ideas 96 I'd shade this
maneuver
who is this country from USA oh I know
who this is
I know who this is
it's only Grandmaster whose name starts
with stem I think he's a student let's
play Knight c7 some nice time advantage
play Bishop g4 expecting 92 otherwise on
my take and now what to do Bishop d7
Bishop d7 there's a funny threats and
threatening Greek gifts with g v g5 alum
potentially trap the bishop let's
imagine before takes takes Knight g4
King g3 g5 that would be nice I moved to
d7 and that e 6 slang might want to play
Knight u6 later so a Bishop Bishop g3
safe move oh that's a problem my bishops
not defend it I could take now let's
take each takes 96 I'll fight for the e4
square
I have Knight g4 two ideas are meeting
eventually I'll bring the other Knight
to g5 well does this you wants to play
Bishop f5 have to allow it Knight g5
looks ok
white might end up taking but H files
opening I might do this thesis and still
try and mate on each file
I mean White's going for a minority
attack or this move what does this move
once ye for probably if I take doesn't
quite work play this move maneuver back
to g6 looks solid booking Queen are
aligned very tender pieces for the
bishop vision of g6 really only move
makes sense
maybe Queen b6 I'm just pressuring
aligning with the King touching the B to
pawn play King g8 expecting rogue h1 now
that's six I'm probably the plan is to
double up and c5 is thematic but it
hangs d5 Queen b3 possible let's just
move back and the knight can come in and
it's kind of like a decoration doesn't
serve any practical value yeah it's
gonna be a dance-off I could play b6 to
prepare eventual c5 it's weakening but
it's playable I'll defend c6 first
they're over defense e6 that's a move I
could take it takes rook e8 maybe who
was this c5
I'm getting interesting McQueen a seven
sneaky move it takes on repeats Queen
takes I win the Knights want to play
rook a eight probably interesting c5
work at all let's play rock AIDS and
white might be able to take hook b3 hmm
I assumed I would have something here
it's not clear this move preparing this
I mean a4 expected like I should start
sacking let's play this move guy take it
away with taking looks so risky play
this move like idea of they should be
five lease it's solid the Knights kind
of stuck actually I want to take care
next couldn't take their last move
because Queen takes rook
when does this move that's a move let's
take play this move yeah it's going to
be a time scramble
I keep both works on the board it's not
gonna be pleasant so alive though
actually positions still reasonable now
let's see winning huh
maybe not the highest quality time
scramble the time scramble nonetheless
well the game I was getting outplayed
but I kept surviving and surviving until
my flagged or until I got a winning
Brook ending pomegranate somethings
fruit snack thanks for subbing well the
new subs appreciate that yeah is it it
it is Jim booyah I believe ya strong
player I have to get experience against
strong players some things fiddler in a
few days I have to get experience
flagging strong players maybe it's a
secret to success crime shoe thanks for
the bits and night c8 thanks for the
bits the Mockingjay says hey guys I am a
1500 player from Germany and I would
like to know if 1700 is a realistic goal
for casual player like me yeah of course
mean anything within 200 grading points
is realistic but I would say in terms of
making goals it's okay to have a rating
goal but make study goals like make
goals where you're aiming to solve a
certain number of tactics every day or
every week
and you're aiming to like place or a
number of training games tournament
games you should focus a lot more on the
learning process rather than the end
results better for long-term growth how
are you preparing for fiddler I'm
learning how to make smoothies
I made the green smoothie transparent
actually it's yeah this green screen
does a good job I'm trying to like be
healthy meeting up to the match it was
more about like frame of mind I did by
lion's mane mushroom powder which is
it's actually like I've tried it a few
times like putting putting it in
smoothies and it does have kind of a
noticeable impact on focus in terms of
chess preparation I'll be playing some
some training matches with friends I'm
gonna try and schedule some more
training matches and a study there's a
pretty good network of people in the
area I can study with so but yeah the
match will be on Sunday there should be
a command up coming coming
yeah 12:00 p.m. Central Time
do you know how to play the English
opening yes English was basically my
main opening before I I started playing
the London but I circling English round
master level I believe chess we'd be
thanks for the host appreciate that
looks like oil yeah you can't know it
has a very like bright green color maybe
I could turn off the chroma key just so
people can see it how I do it filters I
don't want to destroy the filter though
filters
okay so you see you see transparency now
you see green beautiful green
okay back to transparency I will stream
the this Fiddler match also Svidler will
stream with fiddler match it's a
bantering match so we're required to
stream I believe Spitler will stream
from the chest 24 channel I'll stream
from my channel
you